[Music]
he is abusive emotional and verbal abuse
he accused me of molesting our son I
think if we had stayed together it
probably would have turned physical cuz
he was punching walls and kicking dogs
and and that type of thing I don't want
anybody to ever suffer the way that I
have
[Music]
suffered what up what up this is John
with the Dr John show so glad that
you've joined us talking about your
mental and emotional health the things
that are you're struggling with and the
things that are going right good stuff
talking about your marriage talking
about kids we're talking about whatever
you got going on in your life that you
have decided I I I just I can't keep
doing this I want to do something
different if you want to be on this show
talk about your marriage talk about your
mental health talk about your emotional
health parenting physical health even
give me a buzz at
84469 33291 it's 1844 693 3291 or go to
john.com
ask and we're couple weeks out for
Thanksgiving if you haven't already and
if there's still any left go to
johal.com and pick up your the new
questions for humans decks we made one
for Thanksgiving this year we made one
for Christmas this year and we're going
to save your holidays I'm going to save
your holidays don't go into Thanksgiving
talking about politics or you'll burn
your house
down go in with a deck of cards and some
boundaries and you're going to all leave
liking each other John
delone.org and talk to Kristen what's up
Christen hey how are you Dr John good
what are you up to I'm just sitting here
at my house Golding laundry living the
dream that's right the dream laundry
just keeps happening right it does yes
oh gosh man folding laundry it just
feels seemed like the most feudal thing
all right so what's up how can help so I
written in um previously to ask if you
thought it would be a good idea if I
spoke with my ex-husband's new
girlfriend about
his no well there's an update because I
actually did meet with her and talk to
her why why did you do that
well I just I it was just something the
the great the great
Frozen she sang it back well who was it
was it Elsa Elsa sang it best yes yeah
just let it go oh my gosh I can't
believe you did that okay all right
so oh man so you have an ex-husband he's
dating again you love that and you felt
the need were you trying to warn her
about something I was trying to warn her
that he is abusive oh yes gosh okay and
I had spoken to like a Mutual contact
between her and me and just to like get
some advice and the Mutual contact was
like you know if it was me I would want
to know and I kind of felt the same way
if it was me I'd want to know um and
what kind of what kind of abuse physical
abuse like um emotional abuse he's just
annoying he lies a lot emotional and and
verbal abuse um I think if if we had
stayed together it probably would have
turned physical because he was punching
walls and kicking dogs and and that type
of thing um so all right so you did
something I would have told you don't do
call in next time don't ask a mutual
whatever all right so you did it you've
done it how did it go it went really
well I really like her she's she's great
she's uh very kind and gracious and we
sat and had coffee for uh about an hour
and and talked about it and um she she
thanked me for you know letting her know
and she definitely she said she hadn't
seen any signs of that and uh of course
she hasn't right exactly because I mean
we we just got divorced like the divorce
he filed in February of this year was
finalized in May and they started dating
in I guess June or July of this year oh
they were did they were together before
that that's what I'm thinking they were
together before that yes okay so I have
to ask this question
do
did did it feel
better because I know there's a part of
you yes that wanted to warn a fellow
sister out there this is this might come
but I also know a big part of this was I
can't freaking believe he's already
dating again he ruined my life he's not
getting away with this a second
time it wasn't I mean I and I and I told
her that I'm very happy for the both of
them like I wish them the best and I
pray for him every day I pray for them
them together every day
uh so it's it's not a jealousy thing I I
kind of wish it was I feel like it would
be easier to get over if I was just
jealous of her um but she has four kids
and she's also a foster mom and I was
like you I just felt that and I kept
praying about it and it just would not
leave the back of my mind that you know
if if it was me I I would want to know
and that I just and I told her I said I
just I don't want anybody to ever suffer
the way that I have suffered um from all
of it yeah so so that was just kind of
you did it so what's your question
now maybe maybe you don't even have one
you just wanted to sh wanted to share
well I just wanted to know your opinion
but you you let that go
real um I the only time I've ever seen
this
fruitful is when it comes the other
way when a new girlfriend or a new
fiance or a new
um you know a guy's about to get married
and there's kids involved so you've got
you know I don't know if yall do you all
have kids together yes okay so there's
kids involved and the abuse happened in
front of the kids and that that was part
of my thing is like you know she has
kids and foster kids and he had no
problem doing all of this in front of
the kid sure
um man there's so many layers here um if
if you don't have a shred of and maybe
jealousy is the wrong word but if you
don't have a shred of Vengeance in you
um you're better than like you're better
off than
999998 per of
humanity yeah I don't at all I really
she she is so good and I I told her I
was like I really hope that like maybe
you are what makes him change and makes
him better like for the kids sake and
everything I mean she and for her she's
like I know this is awkward but it
really it wasn't awkward for me sure I
just wanted to warn her but I mean she's
great I mean I I really like her and I
hope that they what's the what's the
custody arrangement with your kids and
him um he gets them every first third
and fifth weekends and he gets them
every Thursday night on his off weekends
as well so Thursday to Sunday first
third and Fifth and every Thursday night
okay um the only way I've ever seen it
work really well is if two people sit
down to talk about the
kids like you're like my husband's
dating you my kids are going to be in
your life life here's my expectations
about my kids I want to get to know the
person who's going to be in the life of
my
children I've seen that go well when
people and when everybody's acting like
adults I've seen it be a nightmare when
people are acting like children people
act like adults then I I've seen it go
well people are respectful I've heard of
um men sitting down and saying you're
about to be in the life of my daughter
because you're now dating my ex-wife and
um here's my expectations for the men in
the life of my daughter and then I've
I've heard a couple of times the other
man the new boyfriend and the new fiance
be very respectful like I'm I'm
appreciative that her dad loves her this
much and you've got my word and I'll
call you like all that kind of stuff um
and then I've heard in a couple of rare
cases when somebody calls and says hey
this is a very personal private
conversation this guy's screaming at me
and swearing in front of my kids is this
new or did you experien this
too right I've never seen it go well the
other way the way you the way you did it
so maybe this is the first time ever um
I would be
stunned if she doesn't reach out and be
like so your ex-wife called and said
you're abusive and that that just end
real
well right
so has he reached out to you and like
dude what's your
problem no he hasn't at all I don't know
if she's talked to him about it or not
um I told her that I went into this with
the assumption that whatever I say would
make it back to him yeah she would be a
terrible girlfriend if she
didn't so I I have if if she has told
him he has not said anything to
me oh
man um why didn't the courts side with
you oh we did mediation uhhuh um why did
you let me say it this way if he was so
abusive that you felt the need to go to
his new girlfriend and say watch out for
your own s safety and at this time not
physical safety but own psychological
safety and the sheetrock in your house
safety why did you settle in a mediation
for anything less than this this monster
can't be around my
kids I was being told by my lawyer that
that would not happen um and I have uh
hours of evidence of it towards the end
I mean it got it got uh pretty bad to
the point where he accuse me of
molesting our son um and apparently it
just didn't matter uh cuz that was one
of the things that I was upset about
after mediation with with what he he got
and they said well it that's that's the
best you would have gotten if you had
gone to court um I totally disagree with
that I if the abuse was as real as if
the abuse was so egregious if it was a
guy yelling in his house and saying and
swearing in his house some judges might
not say that's abusive enough to take
away a kid from his
parent but if it's as volatile as you
said it was so much that you need to be
proactive with his new
girlfriend I think you may have got bad
legal advice or your attorneys looked at
what you're experiencing and they were
like it's not as bad as you think it
is yeah and I I had told my attorney
that I wished uh that he had hit me
because people would take it more
seriously no you don't no I mean but in
because I felt like nobody was taking me
seriously nobody was listening um when
it happened yeah and but it was I mean I
was letting everything roll off my back
as it happened because they made us live
together during the divorce part and um
he just attacked me every single day
just about they can't make you live
together yeah they they told us that we
couldn't leave I I kept begging my
lawyer I was like I sent email after
email with you know the evidence I was
like you know it's getting nobody nobody
they can't you're not under house arrest
they can't make you stay in an apartment
or in a home with they said it would not
go well if I left because I kept asking
if we could move out and they said no
and they told him the same thing that it
would look bad if we if we moved out um
so we what would look bad hun that's
insane I have no
idea I guess when it came because we had
to sell the house so I guess when it
came to taking a stake of the equity
like I would be giving up my I'm not
sure what if you moved into an apartment
to keep from getting your your brains
beat in that's
nonsense I mean he he would uh call me
every name under the sun and like
discusting everything that's just the
most in I've never heard that in my life
ever there there has to be something
else here that I don't know about I've
never heard that in my life ever ever
ever in fact I again I don't know the
ins and outs of this case and I'm not a
legal professional but I can see a great
case for in the middle of mediation you
move out because it's so not
safe and that becomes part of the
mediation that he's created such a
hostile living environment for you but
again I'm not in there it doesn't sound
right at all I've never ever heard that
in this particular situation there's a
couple of things that have happened that
I've never ever ever heard ever and I've
seen some been around some wild
situations um and may that doesn't mean
anything that that maybe means this
happens all the time and it just goes
swep under the rug and swep under the
rug and swep under the
rug if I'm you I can't recommend it
enough that you've said your peace
you've talked to his new girlfriend and
this is the end of the road for that
conversation um if you feel the need to
have a conversation about your kids
safety or working with some of your kids
I'd recommend you do it with your
husband or your ex-husband and let that
be that and if you get signs of abuse or
if your kids come home and say dad's
punching holes in the sheetrock again I
want you to call another attorney and
walk them through every single thing you
experienced and everything you went
through and say I can't have my kids
around this anymore I want to file suit
for a new custody Arrangement because my
children aren't
safe but I My Hope Is that you create
another life and you don't know his
dating
status unless he invites you in in or
unless he's bringing somebody else home
around your kids and then you need to
know that but I want you to separate
your life from his you need time to heal
and need time
to this whole thing just sounds like a
mess and I would pull myself out of it
and I would focus my time on my kids and
on my kids safety and he's going to go
do what he's going to go do I hate that
you're in this man it's just such a
messy messy
mess and it just sounds like you got
some gross advice or there's just other
parts of the story but I wish you the
best and I wish that you begin let let
there be a period at the end of this
sentence and go on about healing and
creating your new life cuz you're worth
peace and right now you don't have that
thanks for the call Kristen we'll be
right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey what up what up it's deloney
this time of year can be so hard and
Seasonal effective disorder is real when
I moved here the time change caught me
off guard it was dark at 4:30 and I was
ready for bed at like 6:45 at night
things weren't as fun even food tasted
different and now I know how to prepare
my body I go outside and enjoy nature I
stick to an exercise routine I got a
light box and I intentionally connect
with people another thing that has
helped me therapy therapy can be a
bright spot even when the Sun goes down
too soon something positive to help you
feel grounded and give you the tools to
manage the way your body is changing
during the seasons if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit into your
schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get matched with the
license therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for No Charge find
your bright spot this season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com delone
toay to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
delone all right we are back let's roll
out to louville Kentucky and talk to
Emily what's up Emily hey Dr John how
are you I'm good and you I am awesome
this is a surreal moment for me I'm an
original 17
listener I that's so cool so did you
just like wait and wait until like
you're like oh I've got something and
then you call you know you listen to the
shows over the years and you're like I
can relate to that one or maybe I'd
asked this and then I don't know a
couple weeks ago I just thought kept
thinking about this question and I
thought you know who would have some
good insight for me Dr John and let's
just see what happens and I was so
excited when Jenna called dude that's
the that's the best I'm excited when
Jenna called she doesn't even ever call
call me so that's awesome good for you
it was great it was great thank you
Jenna what's up all right so I wrote it
down so I wouldn't get too nervous but
as a longtime listener I'm surprised I
haven't heard this question yet since I
believe it applies to others and could
help many for the backstory I was 19
when my dad developed pix disease which
is similar to an early onset Alzheimer's
with a sudden personality change
preceding the memory loss sounds like
maybe you've heard of it yeah just a
man yeah yeah so after a lengthy
difficult Journey um he passed away
after about eight years he was only
59 yes yes so fast forward I'm 36 I'm
married I have a four-year-old daughter
and I can't help but ask myself every
day am i g to develop this disease do I
have 14 years left to raise my daughter
yeah yeah and so you can see like it
just gets very overwhelming and so I
know I thought maybe I get a little
upset but I know there are other people
in the same boat as me who think like
okay I'm approaching the age that my
parent passed away too young and what
can I do you know to ease that anxiety
and that fear yeah man especially when
you have your own kids just a bummer
it's way more than just a bummer I mean
you're talking I mean
your your nervous system still developed
when you're
19 yeah
and the the demon of PX is I mean you're
looking at
somebody who's your
dad and he's looking right through you
yeah and it's it's it's and he's right
there right it's like trying to hug a
ghost you see
him right yeah 100% And I think it's you
know we know at some point I think that
we're going to take care of our parents
when we get older you know because no no
no no no no no no hold on hold on you
hold on you man you're good you're
really fast
um you how old are you now 30 36
36 you haven't circled
back and hugged that 19-year-old
Emily because no kid supposed to go
through
that I like to think that I have I've
done therapy over the years I know I
know you've done therapy you've talked
about it you've expressed it you've had
the grief conversations I get that so
many conversations but one of my biggest
frustrations with talk therapy often
is you're we it's all cerebral it's all
thoughts and thoughts and more thoughts
and if I just get all my thoughts in the
right order then everything's
fine
and it's still this many years later you
talk about your dad and you talk about
he's probably a pretty good guy huh yeah
he was pretty great yeah he's pretty
great and then all of a
sudden he would fumble around for the
name of his baby girl
yeah and now you have a four-year-old
and that thought becomes even more
harrowing right because you can see both
sides of the equation now when you're 19
you just experience it one way way like
this is happening to me when you have
your own kid you realize what hell that
was yeah and I don't I mean I don't have
control over that but I don't want to do
that to her you know or my husband or it
just well nobody does and he didn't want
to do he didn't want to do that either
right no
um if you haven't and I know the last
thing you want to hear is I don't want
to see anybody else I want to talk about
this anymore the Audio I get
that if you haven't gone to sit with a
trauma counselor which is different than
grief I'll recommend you doing that even
if it's two or three
sessions and probably what it will be is
you laying down like on a massage table
or you sitting down in a
chair and the counselor sitting just
behind you or right next to you and you
go back to being 19
about three months after you heard about
the diagnosis and then your dad wants to
goes to take you somewhere and he
forgets where he's going to take
you yeah and he looks at you with that
fear that dads aren't supposed to look
at their daughters with because dad's
supposed to have it all
together and what the counselor will do
is just simply put her hand on your
shoulder or hold your hand because your
body's got to cycle it out because it's
still holding on to it
that's number one number
two in the present I want you to not be
upset with the anxiety it's exactly
right at 19 you experience something
that nobody should experience a hope is
right this is a gnarly hope the hope is
we all bury our parents not the other
way around right that's the way it
should be right right
and they should all be 98 and die in the
middle of the night in their sleep yes
with a smile on their face and maybe
like a middle finger to the like to the
Texas Rangers right like something like
that yeah but
not slowly dissolve in front of their
baby girl right and and so
um your body put a GPS pin in that
man and what you have to decide to do is
to feel it and to go oh there it is
trying to protect me again I'm good
now and you have that's got to be a
refrain
a common always happening refrain and
you're going to have to make sweet sweet
piece with a journal and get that crap
out of your body onto the paper because
what your daughter's going to feel as
she gets older and older is your chest
tightening up every time you think of
that moment and then you look at her and
she's going to think that's her fault
whatever that thing that's happening to
mom right now she has to try to solve
that and that's not her job fair no yeah
oh 100% it's not her job
and I try to um do things like leave a
journal for her and you know there's so
many things that I think my dad would
have said to us if he could have or knew
it was coming so sometimes I think well
maybe I can quiet my alarm Bells by
writing down advice that I want her to
know like almost like have you written
your dad a letter in case you're trying
to you're trying to Seance him don't do
that he's gone yeah but he left you mhm
right he left you he left his amazing
beautiful brilliant
daughter what you need to do on a
regular basis for a season is write him
a letter a couple of them okay and
you've heard me on the show say it and I
always say three different ones but you
might need more because he needs to know
what he's missed yeah a lot Dear
Dad I would have loved if you were here
to have punched this guy out that I was
dating when I was 26 you would have
hated him how did you know that you were
like so spot on like and and hopefully
while you're writing you're laugh crying
and imagine your like the best you can
do imagine yourself at a table at a
Denny's talking to your old man yeah and
don't run from that no be the dream to
sit there was again do it but do it with
a pen and if you're a true gangster read
it to your husband out loud oh okay okay
or you want to do something even
crazier this year let's see what you got
this year for Christmas do you have
brothers and sisters I do have an older
sister yeah okay this year you're all
going to write each other a letter from
Dad oh okay dear
sister sure I'm so proud of
you that's a good idea you've got four
amazing kids you bathe properly now
whatever the story is right and with
whatever weird humor your dad probably
had
whatever his seriousness he always um
called us by our initials even though
we're married now I don't know if he
would have changed that if he had have I
would have gotten mad at him of course
yeah you can take whatever name you want
but for him you all right yeah and
here's what we're here's what we're
doing we're teaching our
body a number one we're we're honoring a
great man yeah right who hung on the
best he could for as long as he could
that's number one number two we're
teaching our body
that we're okay now yeah and we're going
to do it in the presence of other people
which I don't know how that works I
don't know the physiology about how that
works I just know that grief has to be
expressed in front of other people yeah
and most of us run from it and that's
what the anxiety is it's running away
from that alarm
system and so this year for Christmas or
Thanksgiving as a as a moment of
Celebration what if you ran into it yeah
walk or walk into it and you'll have one
or two of your siblings that might be
like this is insane I'm not doing this
that's fine it's just my sister and I so
I will not give her a choice yeah she
didn't get a choice is your is your mom
remarried she is yeah okay what if um
the three y'all three women went out and
y'all did it
together and you wrote her a letter from
your dad saying how proud you are of him
and you approve of this knuckleheaded
other guy and and you're so glad that
she has you know what I'm saying yeah it
would probably be very cathartic for all
of us I know it would but very very
scary because it would be like you said
unleashing a lot of trauma over those
years he was sick yeah it's sick but but
here's the thing all of yall are feeling
it yeah and all of y'all have tried to
take care of one another by shoving it
all the way down yeah and that's
anxiety yeah absolutely and I want you
to be really gracious with Emily in the
present yeah have now there's another
part of of of anxiety that's about
choosing reality okay yeah is there any
sort and I don't know enough about this
without getting over my skis is there
any sort of MRI you can go get done to
find out if you're a candidate you can
you can have uh genetic testing done
which my husband's in the military so we
talk about maybe um going down that road
when we're retired and settled I think
you should go down that road right now
oh I don't I know but that Gap
that
Gap the choosing to live in the
deliberate I don't want to know that's
your body trying to get your
attention yeah right and so what we're
going to do is we're going to face
reality is there a teeny teeny tiny
possibility if there is I don't know the
genetic component to it it's about 50%
so it's larger I mean essentially it's
yeah it's scary because I'm like is it
going to be me is it going to be my
sister do you want to know do you want
to know going into those years that you
may or may not have the last you can you
can choose to not want to know but you
cannot get at your body mad at your body
for trying to get your attention because
it's just doing its job true so either
I'm going to choose 15 years of anxiety
and then we're gonna spin the roulette
will or I'm GNA learn right now I'm
going to become one of those crazy
people that goes down every Rabbit Hole
trying to come up with any sort of thing
I can do on the front end to extend it a
year six months five years
whatever I'm going to go to Every
clinical trial I can and I am going to
soak up every second with my daughter
yeah right and I'm going to make sure
there are video logs and journals and
whatever yeah so that when she's sitting
down imagining herself having a
conversation with mom over over Denis
right um she can just push play on the
video exactly you know what I'm saying
yep that's something that I think helps
to quiet my alarm Bells what's that just
knowing that there'll be more for her
like because there's more awareness it
was very but you have been like all
right in 50 years I'm going to pull my
head out of the
sand I think you need to
know yeah I think I do need to know yeah
I think you need to know or just make
peace like dude I'm just I'm just
anxious that's just I'm Gonna Roll I'm
just gonna be super it's the same thing
as like hey how much money do you have
in your checking account like I don't
even want to know I'm just going to keep
going and uh there 50% % chance there's
money in there and 50%
not your body would be failing you if it
wasn't like hey what's in the account
what's in the account what's in the
account um you got to find out what's in
the account I
think I think I think it's always best
to deal with reality and then if you
find out no you're a carrier this is a
really significant chance that you've
got this we're going to grieve that and
we're going to start making some
truthful decisions out of that um that's
just me if you were my sister or my wife
that would be my strongest strongest
recommendation and I know it's scary
scary scary scary and so is not knowing
too but anytime you feel that storm head
into
it and man how amazing of a legacy your
dad left
you this many years later you still miss
him so much and you still smile when you
think about
him I hope my daughter thinks of me that
way when it's my
time hang on the line in I'm going to
send you a copy of building an unanxious
life I want you to read through it and
use the map your body's alarm starts
sitting off I want you to pinpoint it on
the map we can go from there we'll be
right
back hey deloney here good folks our
society has devalued sleep we're told to
keep working and grind through the
fatigue and pretend that we don't need
sleep then this crazy culture tries to
shame us when we do hit the sack at a
normal time I'm here to tell you 7 10
to9 hours of refreshing sleep is
essential for all aspects of your
physical and mental health and to help
with that I recommend investing in an
amazing mattress getting great sleep is
priceless but a premium mattress can
cost a lot and that's a big reason why I
love dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses
are made with premium materials for half
the cost of other premium mattresses
they use Advanced Technologies to keep
you comfortable all night for a great
price and the exclusive deal they're
offering offing my listeners can help
even more right now dreamcloud is
offering my listeners 40% off all
mattresses plus an additional $50
discount go to dreamcloud sleep.com and
enter code John deloney today that's
dreamcloud sleep.com with code John
deloney all right we are back before we
go on to what's next Kelly as of this
recording your boys beat my boys yeah
they
did R my
my 11 to four it was to four yeah it was
not a great game yeah it was it was an
amazing game it was not a great game it
hurt all now the Phillies have been
beaten which I'm so so happy about oh
dude you have a you've got
a if y'all don't win this one it was not
meant to be for the Texas Rangers this
is set up as humanly possible I know I
only problem is we have home field
advantage and that's where we lose our
games as at home all of them yeah we
don't do well at home this is the second
either World Series or Championship
postseason where the Astros have lost
every home game and won every away game
yeah and that we're the same way we just
don't do well at home and so home field
advantage this time like no thank you we
don't want it geez man well I would say
congratulations but boo and it starts on
Friday and come on di backs let's go
Diamond Backs go take it Go Diamond
Backs all right so um we're continuing
the series on the six daily choices and
we shot this uh
Incredible
video um about each one of the six daily
choices if you're watching this on
YouTube um you're going to see it's just
beautifully shot and West frus and his
team have done just an amazing job with
this if you're listening to it the audio
is incredible but also I recommend when
you get done with the podcast if you
know of somebody that would V that would
benefit from this send it to them or go
check it out today's daily choice is
choosing mindfulness and if you're like
me when you hear the word mindfulness I
just roll my eyes it's so so dumb shut
up you me do pilotes and yoga and do
some stretches in my stretchy pants and
by the way I like pilotes and I like
yoga too but whenever I think of
mindfulness Pilates what is it Socrates
Socrates pilates pilates pilates what
did I say pilotes pilotes that's like I
Italian it's Pilates from bill and teds
when they used to be like so crates I
always think pilates
pilates and I'm not bagging on that I'm
just saying like when someone says
mindfulness I just imagine this like old
guy with a beard on a cloud just
going and I'm like dude I ain't got time
for that like I got a kid a middle
schooler who's like Dad ah I have a
seven-year-old like can I have a snack
can I have a snack can I have a snack
and I've got like a job and I got Kelly
in my life for God's sakes and all the
stuff and I don't have time for
mindfulness it's not what I'm talking
about and dude I really writing the book
I really wrestled with is there another
way to say this and it just was not
honest if I didn't just call it what it
was so if you've ever heard the word
mindfulness and you're like all right
that's enough of that stay with me stay
with me on this I want you to listen to
the whole segment here um and if you're
watching it stop what you're doing for a
second give me seven or eight minutes of
your time and plug directly
in nothing else in the six daily choices
has rattled my cage more than this idea
of
mindfulness check it out here we go six
daily choices choose
mindfulness most of us live completely
unfree completely outsourced completely
automated lives and everyone is spending
all of their energy responding to the
Past running out and trying to
anticipate the future and we don't have
the skills to be present where we
are mindfulness is simply the gap
between stimulus and response between my
body feels this thing and what do I do
next
how do you lengthen that Gap so choosing
mindfulness as a part of building a
non-anxious life is cultivating two
important ways of doing life being aware
and being
[Music]
curious think of awareness as ownership
of your life at
360° Can You Feel the good stuff and the
bad stuff can you feel this might happen
and can you also feel but it probably
won't awareness is looking around your
life and taking inventory and ownership
of it when somebody cuts you off in
traffic and your body instantly responds
with a story that you've made up about
the driver of that car that's not being
aware that's being automated and dumping
it on that guy in that car because you
can also choose another story you can
sharply inake your breath until you know
you're safe and you can
exhale you get to decide The Narrative
and you get to ask yourself this
question why is my body responding like
that what is my body trying to protect
me from when you get an email at 4:00 on
a Friday from your boss that says I need
to see you immediately why does your
body instantly go to war why does your
body instantly want to Sprint to the
parking lot and drive away is it because
you have an untrustworthy boss is it
because you you know you're about to get
fired or is it because since you were a
little kid anytime an adult called you
on the carpet you knew you were going to
get scolded and shamed and hit and this
boss is just another adult in a long
line of people who treated you less than
awareness is about looking at your
entire life taking ownership of how you
feel and that leads me to
[Music]
curiosity curiosity is the choice to not
instantly judge throw rocks at take
swings at people at actions at ideas
curiosity is sitting back back and
asking why did she say that I wonder why
that politician keeps doing that I
wonder why the teacher at my kid School
said that instead of instantly jumping
to fight or flight or freeze instead of
instantly jumping towards I have to
react I have to go do being aware of how
your body is responding to certain
things and being curious about why
that's
happening gives you a moment to breathe
and it gives you a moment to decide what
happens
next so when you first start being
Mindful and you first start being aware
of things and being curious about things
you're going to be overwhelmed with
feelings and it's important to
understand feelings are not designed to
tell you the truth feelings are designed
to keep you safe feelings are designed
to keep you connected even if that
connection's
unsafe feelings are not designed to tell
you the truth they are data but they're
corrupted data they're important but
they don't tell the truth and so an
important part of being curious being
aware is asking the question is that
true is that for real is your husband
really the worst person ever is your
boss really the worst person ever most
people are just like you doing the best
they can to get through the day and they
want friends and they want laughter and
they want connection and they want huh
never thought of it that way or they
want that's stupid that's mindfulness
that's
awareness somebody would call into my
show they call in and say hey John I've
heard you screaming and yelling at your
kids especially when they're little
hurts them it's not good but my
5-year-old keeps banging everything and
my 3-year-old keeps pulling everything
off the counters and every time I clean
up this mess they're over here making up
a new mess and my newborn won't stop
screaming and so finally when my
5-year-old comes down and says can I
have a snack can I have a snack can I
have a snack I snap and I yell and
scream how do I not do
that this is where mindfulness comes
into play this is where awareness and
curiosity save the
day because let's back up for one second
right before you yell let's be aware
this is your feelings not theirs this is
your rage and anger and frustration and
it shouldn't be this way not theirs and
awareness gives us one tiny little
millisecond before we respond and in
that millisecond we can remember they're
five of course they bang on things
they're three of course they don't have
motor control and they just want to see
what happens when they pull a thing off
the wall and that leads us to curiosity
why am I so enraged
oh cuz I thought motherhood would feel
different I thought my kids would behave
if I was a good mom I didn't realize
kids sometimes misbehave just because
they're kids and it was my expectations
and it was my bricks in my backpack that
I brought to this scenario not theirs
and then you can smile and you can go
this isn't the season for a clean house
this isn't the season for Perfection
this isn't the season for doing
everything
perfectly this is the season when I have
a infant and a 3-year-old and a
5-year-old and you can make
peace
so I left work the other day and I was
raged out I was super angry and in the
car I was driving home and I started
laughing and I was like how is this
solving this right like there was there
was nothing I could do about what I was
mad about in my car on my way to my
house being
angry driving too fast grabbing the
wheel that tight solved none of my
issues and so then I texted my wife and
said something I don't like to say I had
a hard one today I'm coming in kind of
hot and she said I'll have dinner and a
hug and a show ready cuz those are
things that aren't going to solve my
problem at work but it is going to make
me more whole right whenever I get spun
up on something what can I control about
this thing mindfulness it's about being
aware it's about being curious is this
actually working for me is this actually
provid guiding me relief from the thing
I'm so upset or frustrated about
mindfulness will save you it'll save us
all hey what's up delone here listen you
and me and everybody else on the planet
has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choic choices
that you can make to get rid of your
anxious feelings and be able to better
respond to whatever life throws at you
so you can build a more peaceful
nonanxious life get your copy today at
John
delone.org
name for a band ever it's kind of
excessive great song Somebody told me
and it goes like this breaking my back
just to know your name 17 tracks and
I've had it with this game I'm breaking
my back just to know your name but
Heaven Ain't close in a place like this
anything goes but don't blink you might
miss cuz heaven ain't close in a place
like this I said Heaven Ain't close in a
place like this bring it back down never
thought I'd let a rumor ruin my
Moonlight somebody told me you had a
boyfriend who looked like a girlfriend
that I had in February of last year not
confidential I've got potential let's
roll into something new taking its told
and I'm leaving without
[Music]
you how true this is man gosh they're
good hey I love y'all stay in school
don't do drugs
bye